hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast protect your research
know your v6 mouse I am Brenda Kelly Kim
elaborates and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
The Jackson Laboratory the Jackson
Laboratory is an independent nonprofit
organization focusing on main mammalian
genetics research to advance human
health for more information please visit
WWE CEO we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is intended to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the green
Q&A button which can be found by
clicking in the box Willie left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you have
any technical problems hearing or seeing
this presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left I would now like to introduce
today's speaker dr. Brian Soper dr.
Sopher has worked at The Jackson
Laboratory for 20 years he is currently
a technical information services
scientist dr. Soper's area of expertise
is in modeling and complications
associated with human type 1 and type 2
diabetes and research with
immunodeficient mice I will now turn it
over to dr. Sopher for his presentation
Thank You Brenda thank you very much for
that introduction and welcome everyone
to our presentation this morning this
talk is going to focus on the c57 black
six miles in the purpose of this
presentation is to educate you about the
difference is between different
substrains of the mice overall with the
goal to help improve your research and
help you make better interpretations of
your scientific data before I do that
I'm just going to do a couple of
introductory slides related to the
jackson laboratory because a lot of
people recognize us as an institution
that distributes mice and the number of
different inbred strains including the
c57 black six but we also much more than
that we're nonprofit research institute
and the laboratories mission is to
perform our own grant funded research
and to use mice as a genetic tool to
understand a wide range of genetic
diseases and look forward Prevention's
cures etc for the goal of improving
health of the human population overall
but the founder of The Jackson
Laboratory CC little was an educator so
he was interested in sharing these
resources and as you'll see in a few
moments he was a creator of a number of
inbred strains of mice and wanted to
share those mice with a broader
scientific community so we became this
institution that was doing our own
research and we were sharing my stuff we
were creating and then eventually we
became a repository and we're also
sharing a lot of resources and I'll give
you some examples of those in just a
minute that can help you with your
research and help understand these
research animals much better and so we
do a lot of education as well we come
out to facilities we provide education
programs you can come to our facility in
Bar Harbor name and take a number of
courses and conferences so if you're
interested in that take a look at the
link that's provided
of the page but of course we do
distribute the mice and we are one of
the world's largest repositories of
genetically engineered mice we import
about five or six hundred new strains
every single year we are funded by the
National Institutes of Health here in
the United States to help support that
colony them I all those mice they give
us funding so that we can import lead
arrived crop preserve those strains even
if those strains are not in a you know
live and breeding on the shelf you can
get them from crying recovery and
they'll be available for your research
fuller eggs for as long as they we have
the funding to do so so we have more
than 7,000 strains in our collection as
i said we improve and interrogate their
health of genetic quality etc and it's
the proceeds of mice like to see 57
black six the belv seeds DBA mines it's
the proceeds of those that go back into
this resource to help provide funding
and allow us to maintain those unique
knockouts transgenics etc if some of the
resources that you should make yourself
available that are freely open to you
use on our website the first of which is
to jax mice database if you are
searching for unique strains of mice i
would encourage you to use the link at
the top of the page oops shown here on
the clear zones are it's a this one here
there's a common search box here on all
of our web pages but it is the one is
the blue link that says the jacks mice
database will you actually do your
searching and you'll get the page that's
shown here and you'll find much greater
success in finding the strains that
you're interested in the most union for
wed informatics website is put together
by our informatics group here what
they're doing is searching through the
scientific literature and have developed
this centralized database which is a
collection point for all the different
publications on genetically modified
mice their alleles expression gene
expression most or biology there's a
wide range of information there you
should take a look at if you need to
know
more about my sign mais and it's a great
place to find mice even if they're not
located subjects laboratory and are
available from some of the other public
repositories around the world then of
course i'll touch on some of this data
as we go through this presentation
there's a database called the mouse
genome database this is a really
powerful tool that will help you
understand the basic phenotypes are
these different inbred strains of mice
and allows you to do side-by-side
comparisons so we'll come back to that
as we go through the presentation okay
so let's talking about this c57 black
six nice and what I'm going to start
with here is I've got three pictures of
mice a B and C and I ask the question
which two of these mice are the most
similar and as you can probably guess
this is kind of a trick question because
most people would look at animals in
Figure B in figure City and say well
those are the mice to look most
identical so they must be the most
similar the answer is that actually a
and B are the most similar the reason
for this is that both of these have the
same genetic background you have the c57
black 6j genetic background and really
the only difference between these two
strains is a difference in a single
allele this is the teronis allele and
this is a single point mutation that
arose in that a little and it's a
spontaneous mutation and it causes them
rice to be L die now in fact we have
recently what we call refresh the
genetic background of these nice to the
seafood ec7 c57 black 6j genetic
background and so they are very much
identical and I'll explain to you the
difference in the c57 black six mjm eyes
those mice are a downstream offshoot
from the c57 black 16 which is the
original line but these two strains in B
and C differ very significantly in terms
of metabolism neurobiology immunology
vision and hearing and behavior and I'll
go through a number of examples of that
and I'll also provide some important
examples of how this can impact your
research depending on which one of these
mice you choose as controls now this
strain is a very important strain for
everyone's research because many years
ago people have chosen an inbred strain
of mice in which you do these genetic
manipulations create knockouts
transgenics etcetera and the reason the
scientist material google shows a
particular inbred strain of mice is so
that when someone changed one expression
of one allele and versus another wheel
in a particular metabolic pathway
analogical pathway they needed a strain
with the same genetic background so that
everyone understood at the time that
each one of these genes functions in the
context of the whole genome so the idea
was that we would change one gene at a
time and they would do it in the context
of an immigrant background all get some
more examples about what an inbred
strain is in a moment I will say very
quickly here too that we have both of
these strains at the genetic back at the
genetic at The Jackson Laboratory excuse
me they have different stock numbers so
that you can identify them by that and
order them accordingly we do have them
at different health says from our button
high barrier and summer at standard
barrier so you can look at their health
reports and see the differences there so
before we get going let's talk a little
bit more about inbred mice the origins
and goodbye nice and we'll talk a little
bit about the history of the black six
mouth so you can understand a little bit
more about this because this will set
the stage for everything else that we're
going to talk about later okay so back
in the early 1900's there was a number
of people that were brooding mice just
essentially for the pleasure and taking
them off to shows knees were called the
mouse fanciers one of these fanciers was
centralized in granbury massachusetts
her name was Eddie lathrup and she
raised and sold these mice and bottom
two shows etc and she offered up some of
her strings to the abusive Institute at
her
and the reason the scientists at Harvard
were interested in these mice it is
because the mouse itself was seen as a
great tool to understand the malian
genetics they're small and easy to
maintain they have great reproductive
performance they have large litters
they're in and their anatomy and
physiology was very similar to human
population so one of the early adopters
of using mice and genetic research
where's dr. William castle he was at the
Busey Institute of Harbor and he
realized that if you began in breeding
these mice you could make these animals
genetically uniform and shortly after he
began doing something similar he um
student that came along and his name was
dr. CC little who turned out to be the
founder of The Jackson Laboratory of our
Harbor Maine in 1929 and so dr. C
Sealand began doing some of these in
breeding experiments and creating new
lines of mice because he was interested
in understanding the genetic basis of
cancer and and understanding those jeans
and transferring cells between different
inbred strains of mice so he got some
the mice from dr. Les Mis Eddie lathrup
and he got female number 57 and he began
including those mice doing brother
sister breeding successive generation he
would breathe those mice together and as
he began breeding these mice they began
segregating coat colors and of course as
you can see here you have the black
brown and 11 that began coming out of
these mice as some of these alleles
became homozygous many of them were
homozygous recessive and as you can see
in terms of the nomenclature for this
you have the black we have the sea from
CC little Clarence cooked liver little
and we have the 57 so we have the c57
black the sea 57 brown and a c57 led
from the c57 black line there was two
sub lines that were generated the six
sub line and the 10 sub line and so
you'll see those mice as a see fig seven
black six and a c37 black 10 okay so
what are some of the advantages of using
inbred strains and why was this done
well first of all the procedure for
doing this is to use pedigree breeding
and breed brothers sisters and do this
over the course of twenty generations
and that what that will do is lead to
genetic homogeneity essentially what
this is doing is leading to all of the
best range within all the alleles within
the genetic background become
homogeneous to become homicidal and
therefore each time you breed a brother
and sister the offspring are produced
from that are to be homozygous for every
single wheel in a genetic background and
the purpose of doing this is generating
very statistical reproducing ghal mouse
that you do a particular test with
treated with drugs versus vehicle for
example all those nice should respond
very very similarly if the strain is a
segregated alleles and you do the same
kind of thing with an upgrade population
you get a lot of statistical variation
in terms of response so shown here is a
standard pedigree breeding you have the
parentals shown here and then you take
two of their offspring this is a brother
and sister you bring them together and
they make a new litter here and you
select a new brother sister from there
and so on and so on so there's something
very important to recognize about this
and this is the idea that you use this
twenty generations of inbreeding to
create these embed strains of mice but
interestingly enough the genome is very
dynamic there's a lot of changes that
can occur over time during each
generation as you're copying and
reproducing this DNA there's a lot of
mistakes that happen there's a lot of
spontaneous mutations that occur and
there's a lot of other changes that go
on so the strains do change over time
and this is what leads to the
of the development of a substrate so as
shown here on this slide for example if
two different laboratories lab a and lab
be get mice from an original source so
they have a c57 black six para colony
lab a does a number of sibling breedings
for ten generations lab be does submit
in breeding and does that for twenty
generations those generations can add up
very quickly and within those different
generations there's some mathematical
calculations that have been done more
recently and we found that the
likelihood that there's going to be a
mutation within a ten generations is
very high the calculations are some
running in Megan order of six to ten
generation six to ten mutations for
every ten generations of breeding and so
these two labs have been breeding and
this is edited between these two labs
and labs a and B these two minus
colonies are actually 30 generations
apart so there's a probability of at
least an accumulative number of
mutations that have been generated
between those two labs some are in the
order of about three new genetic
mutations between those so it's very
important to understand that substrains
can develop very quickly do this genetic
change even though you're doing brother
sister inbreeding so here's a little
more historical perspective on man there
are many different substrains of the 67
black six mice so this is a diagram
showing the progression and the
development of sub strains of mice dr.
[ __ ] little creative dismally said we
just talked about in 1951 he gave Rose
mice to the National Institutes of
Health and United States and from the
National Institutes of Health no strain
that strain was shared with many
different laboratories so what you're
looking at the bottom of this chart is
you're seeing a good what we call lab
codes each time a strain goes to a lab
and it's being bred there and it's being
bred for many generations it should be
assigned a lab coat
so when you see c57 black six and mice
the M stands for the National Institutes
of Health in each one of these lab codes
at the bottom of this chart indicates
either the laboratory which those
strains of being maintained or the
initials of the investigator who are
maintaining those strains so even in our
collection a lot of these streams have
come back to the Jackson Laboratory in
fact the dependents subline turn back to
the Jackson Laboratory in the year two
thousand three so we have both the 67
black 6j and a c57 black 6 MJ so the J
in this nomenclature stands for The
Jackson Laboratory because this is our
lab code and it indicates that these
strains are being distributed by us but
we have several other inbred strains of
substrains of the season seven black six
mice we have the H a the B why in the e
I and they stand for the names of the
investigators that maintain these
substrains from in a year doctor-who
shoka dr. Bailey and dr. Iker in each
one of these strains has unique genetics
and uni phenotypes so it's very
important that if you're maintaining
your own colony see if in some black six
mice reporting in the literature you
should add your own lab code and you can
find out and get an assigned lab code by
looking at the link at the bottom of the
page here okay but one of the questions
and I think it's quite obvious as we're
going to each presentation now is that
our CP all black six mice the same a
black six is a black sixes of black six
well clearly that is not the case and
we're finding more and more scientific
evidence for that and I'm going to
provide you with some examples these
different inbred strains of mice differ
at what we call single nucleotide
polymorphisms or snips they are
different in terms of insertions and
deletions that have happened in their
genomes or many years of inbreeding they
have copy number variations that expand
and contract from one generation to the
next and they develop a number of
spontaneous mutations as well
and as I said earlier these differences
in their genome obviously are going to
lead to differences in metabolic
phenotypes neurobiology including
behavior vision hearing there's a
logical differences and responses
between these strains and many many more
okay so let's go through some of the
examples of this of you're well aware of
it so the primary to substrains that I'm
going to be focusing on the c57 black 6j
and the c57 black six and the sub strain
and some of the data that I'm going to
be showing you is different sources of
the season seven black six and a few
years ago there was a published report
that the c57 black 6j mice have
developed a homozygous mutation for the
wheel called nmt nnt stands for
nicotinamide nucleotide trans
hydrogenase this is a mitochondrial
membrane protein pump that affects ATP
production and this as i said the c57
black 6j mice are known for this
mutation in this rule is a lot of
interest in the scientific community
because the c57 black six mice if you
put them in a very high fat diet they'll
develop a very obese phenotype and
they'll to be developed the beginning
developed many of the early symptoms of
diabetes so their model of prediabetes
obviously one of the characteristics of
that is that the longer they're on this
high fat diet did more weight than again
as soon as there was some concern about
what was the impact of this a wheel I'm
diet-induced obesity and so one of our
longtime diabetes researchers dr. ed
Leiter said well let's take these two
inbred strains of mice one with this nmt
allele and worm wild-type they black 6nj
are completely wild type for n NT let's
put them in the same exact environment
let's put them on the same exact high
fat diet and let's measure these
different pre-diabetic phenotypes
including weight gain and that's what
we're looking at this chart here these
are these two inbred strains the black
line refers to the c57 black 6j and the
red line refers to c57 black 6nj
a normal weight on a mouse that a normal
child diet is going to have a curve that
mice we have a a weight that would be
somewhere around down here by 20 weeks
on a normal child diet these animals are
only about 25 to 30 to 35 grams Max and
what you can see is that both of these
inbred strains of mice have a weight
gain that is very significant upwards of
over 40 grams by 20 weeks any but you
can see that the overall weight gain
between these two end restrains is is
very different and so if you do another
way to measure the phenotypes of these
two strains on this high fat diet is
what's called a glucose tolerance test
after the mice have been on a high fat
diet for different periods of time what
you can do is fast them and then you can
inject a bolus of glucose and what
you're asking these monies to do is
clear that glucose from the bloodstream
over a set period of time so what we've
got is glucose concentration on the
y-axis of these two graphs and then
you've got different time points in
which you've sampled their blood and
measure glucose concentration in the
peripheral blood so what you should be
able to do is challenge the spice with
glucose and if they are not having
pre-diabetic symptoms they should be
able to clear the glucose very quickly
so the time course is every 30 minutes
you take a blood sample which you can
see even after two weeks the rate at
which they can clear glucose from the
bloodstream is very much slowed and that
gets even worse as the longer they're on
the diet's they have 14 weeks on a high
fat you can see that that curve flattens
out very different differently very very
slowly so the other thing I want to
point out here is particularly at this
graph on the right let's say you've
genetically modified the c57 black six
months and you've created a knockout
mutation or you've added a transgene and
you're trying to rep say in most cases
try to improve the clearance of blood
glucose with your genetic modification
you can see that if your data wear my
red arrow shows here come fall somewhere
in between here
and if you chose the black line c57
black 6j you could say that your allele
has improved blood glucose clearance
based on comparison to your controls
however if your strings actually on the
c57 black 6 and genetic background you
might interpret your data saying that
your genetic modification has actually
worsened the blood glucose levels so the
choice of your controls and how you
compare them can completely change the
interpretation of your in scientific
data if your data falls in between those
two so it's in well provide some more
examples of that clean up here first
i'll just show you that here's an
example of another in bed straining
icici seven black six mice this is a
string in in bed state of mouse that was
went from The Jackson Laboratory in Bar
Harbor Maine in the early forties it
went to the France went to a laboratory
in France and is being maintained their
other since these particular mice if
they're placed on a high-fat diet they
do not have any weight gain and so
they're completely resistant to
diet-induced obesity and you can see
that as comparison shown here in the red
lines either on a high-fat or a normal
child diet and neither neither one of
these mice have this high awaking this
is the c57 black 6m substring and
showing its response to the high-fat
diet what's also interesting is you
might ask the question well maybe they
just eat less they don't need as much as
the high-fat diet and as you look at the
food intake intake of this unique inbred
strain of mice which by the way is not
distributed by The Jackson Laboratory
they actually have greater farina take
both on the chow diet and on a high-fat
diet so it's not due to Lord food intake
there's something fundamentally
different different about the genetics
of these mice so here's another example
looking at neurological differences so
here's a published report where you're
an investigator was doing some
neurobiology and he obtains three
different inbred strains of mice one of
the one of them was the c57 black 6j one
was a sub
drink called c57 black six and it was
distributed by charles river
laboratories in the united kingdom and a
third one is the c57 black 6j that went
to heroin laboratories and was
maintained for many generations in the
united kingdom in here they were looking
at a particular gene called alpha
synuclein and what they found in this
paper is the black 6j and the n crl
substrain were completely normal and
wild-type for alpha synuclein expression
but this third substrain the one the ola
HSD was had a deletion in alpha
synuclein that had a period in this
coloring had been fixed in the colony
after many generations and this is
important because this is a gene that
produces a protein that is a structural
component of nui bodies which is found
in parkinson's disease so it could
impact a number of different
neurological disorders so having that
information is very very important it
when working with that strain in
introducing genetic modifications
associated with some of those unique
pathways in neurobiology here's another
example of some behavioral differences
between the two substrains black 6j of
black 610 the black 6j mice very
interestingly have a proclivity for
alcohol and morphine consumption and
it's shown in these graphics they have
very high consumption even at very
different concentrations of alcohol so
this concentration is on the bottom and
we're looking at their average daily
consumption over a period of time we've
got a J in the top curve and the black
6n and the bottom curve and so there's
an overall greater consumption black 6j
also if you look at the preference for
alcohol in other words you expose these
two different strains they had a choice
of drinking alcohol a choice of drinking
water these black six mice will choose
the alcohol over the water in most cases
and at different concentrations and
these in the black 6j has an even
greater preference for choosing alcohol
than black six and substrate
okay so there's a number of ways that a
lot of these things can impact their
research the c57 black 6j might have a
very old mutation in a gene called cdh
23 this is a gene in what's called
age-related hearing loss of the AHL
superscript so these spies developed a
hearing loss at a very young age so this
can impact a number of disease areas of
research if you're not aware of this
this could impact your research in terms
of measuring different diseases and
phenotypes particularly things like
cognitive behavior and because a number
of cognitive assays rely on auditory cue
auditory stimulus so if you're looking
at different neurological changes in
behavior you're writing an essay that
requires an auditory cue the mice are
deaf and they're never going to hear
that auditory cues and could impact how
you're reading those those behavioral
assays so that could impact research
areas like autism anxiety and stress
disorders addiction and even
cardiovascular function because people
use auditory startle reflex and look how
that impacts a cardiovascular function
there are visual changes and differences
between these mice very recently did
black 6 n substrain has been noted to
contain a homozygous vacation called the
retinal degeneration 8 or rd8 mutation
this isn't a gene called crb 1 this gene
is localized to what's called the
Mueller cells that attaches to the rods
and cones crb one is shown here so it's
the interface between these two
different molecules defects in this
mutation have been associated with human
population with retinitis pigmentosa and
leber congenital analysis what this
leads to in the mice is a very early and
progressive spotty retinal degeneration
of mice and here's an example of this
retinal degeneration on the
and mice shown here okay so what this is
it's a single base deletion it allows
some time after the mice were donated to
the billion to the National Institutes
of Health so all of the 67 black six and
substrains have this I v8 mutation the
paper that's shown here shows that all
of the different end sub strains that
you can get from Harlem agua Tories
Charles River Frederick and taconic and
now since the black six and have come
back to the jackson laboratory all of
these end sub streams have this retinal
degeneration mutation what you're
looking at here in this graphic is
capillary electrophoresis they can look
at the deletion of the single base pair
you can see that the black 6m substrain
and the c57 black 10 sub straining which
one before the strains were donated to
the National Institutes of Health both
of those are wild type for RDA and all
the other substrains with the end
nomenclature have the mutation okay so
this has a lot of impact on a wide range
of disease areas obviously anyone who is
creating a genetic mutation or a
transgene and putting it on the 67 black
6 and background and doing I research or
doing behavioral research that requires
the mice to have a visual acuity that
are looking for visual cues and looking
for behavioral responses associated with
that I'm going to have defects and
therefore it's going to impact your
research so there's a lot of behavioral
studies to that include again
Alzheimer's autism Down syndrome rett
syndrome and a lot of other
neurodegenerative disorders when the
mice have behavioral defects is to c57
black 6 and minus is being used in these
behavioral studies they're going to be
blind at a young age and it's going to
impact that research so I'd also like
you to be aware of what's going on in
the broader scientific community in
terms of generating mice and generating
them on the different backgrounds there
are many many years ago as i said the
c57 black 6 j subst rating was chosen
for
creating original knockouts transgenics
etc that was the most common string that
was used but now people are using more
and more the 67 black 6n substrate and
why is dead well for many years we
didn't have any embryonic stem cells
associated with the c57 black 6j
substrate Aidan embryonic strat strat
embryonic cell was created for the black
6m substrate and you need an embryonic
stem cells that you could create knock
out and knock in mutations through
homologous recombination so there's a
consortium that was formed in terms of
trying to knock out every single allele
in a black six genetic background this
is called the International knockout
Mouse consortium this is an
international effort the knockout mouse
project is called comp in the United
States it's called you come in Europe
and it's called Norcom in Canada and
there it a global effort to knock out
every single gene in the mouse genome so
that we can understand a wide range of
genetic influences and combine these
alleles and it's an interesting effort
because you can not only do global
knockouts in the mice the alleles are
being designed so that you could do
conditional Newtons you can knock out
James Justin deliver just in the heart
of just in the brain there's also a
consortium by the Texas aann Institute
for genomic medicine there they've
created a very enormous gene trap
library and they've also used the black
six nds cells so this is very important
to alert you that there's going to be a
huge number of these new genetic tools
that would be available to the
scientific community they're all going
to be on the black six and genetic
background so the secret seven black six
and mice should be chosen as the
controls for audio studies now related
to more related to what we're talking
about here this morning is the cadet
that now many of these knockouts have
been created and now the ES cells are
being microinjected to create inbred
strains of mice and now they're going
into Phase two of the
program where these mice are entering
the corn or call a Fiat typing program
there's multiple institutions around
Europe and in the United States to
phenotype these different nice because
as you can imagine this is a very large
undertaking so one of the things that
people have been doing to validate their
phenotyping program is setting some
baseline data and of course of doing
that there's multiple phenotyping
Institute's that have compared the CT
seven black 6j because it's c57 black
six and substrains running those animals
side by side through the phenotyping
program and so the publication that you
see here at the bottom of this slide is
reporting some of that phenotyping data
and reporting some of the differences
between the phenotypes of these
different substrains so these are the
different phenotypes that you see on
this side there's a comparison between
males and females obviously males and
females have different phenotypes but
we're also looking at different
institutions and these are the codes for
some of the different institutions that
have run these phenotyping pipelines and
that are being reported in this paper so
what's being reported and published here
is phenotypes that show difference
between black 6j and black 6 and and
they show the same difference in
phenotypes between different
institutions so these are repetitive
phenotypes between these different
institutions and they use different
color codes where gray indicated that
there was no difference in phenotypes
red is indicating that one strain with
greater than the other and blue was it
was much less than the other so if they
have bright colors it indicates there's
significant phenotype differences
between these strains and so that you
can see that there's a wide range of
phenotypes and a wide range of
phenotypes that differ quite
dramatically between these two your bed
strains of mice and here's some examples
and these are a number of these I'll go
back for a minute these are
acoustic startle differences differences
in blood clinical chemistry's like
glucose urea sodium potassium chloride
differences in blue ko's clearance
oxygen consumption things like that so
here's another example from the same
paper taking a look at the immunological
differences between these strains and
this is a response to bacterial
infection exposing the mice to listeria
and looking for pro inflammatory
responses looking for the ability of
these inbred strains of mice to fight
infection and looking at as shown here
percent survival and this is broken down
in the two black triangles black six
Jade males and females versus black six
and males and females and you can see
that there are differences in the
overall survival of these mice with the
black six and females having the poorest
survival and the black 6j males having
the greatest in survival after exposure
to a mysterious species and this is some
data showing over here looking at the
pro inflammatory response after exposure
the production of interleukin-6 ip-10
and CCL 2 which are pulled for pro
inflammatory molecules and we can see
very significantly that the oops excuse
me the male's by day three of what would
be the black six and mice shown here
have a very strong immunological
response on day three so there are some
very different responses in logically
between these strains here's some more
examples of that here's an example of
what's called a delayed type
hypersensitivity response basically what
you do is you apply a pemmican called I
natural flora benzing to the skin and
you do that with a two successive
exposures what this is doing its
sensitizing the immune system to this
compound you wait a period of time and
then you challenge the skin with a new
application and the micellar pro
inflammatory response that is measured
by insulation or some
swelling and you can measure that
swelling response and what they see is
that there is a difference between the
black 6j females and males compared to
the black 6n and you see this difference
in a swelling response and you could
actually see through genic analysis that
there are differences in genetics that
are directly associated with differences
in this inflammatory response okay so
it's important for you to know which
inbred strain you're working with and
it's different it's important for you as
you interrogate the different strains
that you distribute it to jackson
laboratory to really look carefully at
the strain development know where those
streams came from and understanding the
genetic backgrounds here you're
selecting the appropriate controls right
now we have over 2,500 strains that are
knockouts transgenic mice etc there on a
c57 black 6j genetic background but the
strains that are coming into us are
better on the 67 black 6m substrate
background are growing dramatically this
is permanent because we have funding as
part of what's called the comp to
project this is the phenotyping arm of
the knockout mouse project what we're
doing is we're importing these ES cells
that contain these genetic modifications
were microinjected them creating global
knockout mutations of them and running
them through a phenotyping program and
then for a period of time these mites
are going to be available for
distributed distribution there are a
number of different research institutes
around the United States and around the
world that are doing that we are
obviously one of these organizations
part of the comp to but there's two
others there's Baylor College of
Medicine Houston that have
collaborations with the Wellcome Trust
in England the medical research council
in Harwell and oxfordshire in England
and then also at the University of
California Davis who is collaborative
programs with the Toronto rule cancer
for fino genomics in Canada
the Children's Hospital in Oakland which
is in California and Charles our
laboratories in Wilmington mass so you
can see that this is a
multi-institutional global effort to
create these mice and phenotype done so
because of that we're going to have a
large number of these mice and growing
and available we're going to have about
eight hundred and thirty mice from the
comp to program and another two hundred
strains from the Yukon program so yeah I
would encourage you to go through these
different websites for the organizations
that are developing these because the
alleles that are being created have some
slight differences and you should go to
these different websites really
understand these alleles in detail okay
so considerations for control selection
I'd really demonstrate to you that there
are some really major differences
between these inbred substrains so what
are some of the things that you should
be thinking about about some of these
other grains of rice in terms of
choosing the most appropriate control
obviously the best is if the gene is
segregating in other words you're
breeding at by a hat-head by wild type
or hemizygous in terms of a transgene by
wild type you're producing wild-type
controls directly from the breeding
colony those nice are going to have the
genetic background that is one hundred
percent matched from the mice that have
your affected allele those are the best
controls of course to be music but of
course in many instances for convenience
of raising those mice people have gone
to a homozygous by homozygous breeding
colony there are no wild type controls
being produced so it's up to you to
understand that gin and background a bit
nice and you're going to have to have a
parallel colony of the wild-type
controls and so you need to be careful
about things like genetic drift how
tightly are and how closely genetically
are those two strains of mice that are
being bred and parallel so also be aware
that people are just beginning to be
cognizant of these differences between
these two inbred strains of mice and
what we're finding is that some of these
strings that are being donated to us are
actually a mix of
to genetic backgrounds so if you have a
homicide of this colony that is a mix of
these two related backgrounds you're
going to have to figure out a way to
develop a colony of controls that is an
appropriate genetic match in terms of
being a mixture between these two so
here's an example of how this is
impacted some other scientists and their
research this is a research publication
or some scientists were looking at the
cinema thing induced liver injury model
in other words you treat the mice with
acetaminophen you look at some of the
clinical chemistry's in the blood and
you look at some histopathological data
from those nice and they were looking at
a particular gene that affected that
pathway and this was called the J and K
2 in the paper but the official gingy
nomenclature for that is Matt canine and
so what they originally thought was that
the genetic background of these mice
with deceitfully sudden black 6j so they
you see for the Sun black 6j is the
wild-type controls and they looked at
production of a liver enzyme called alt
and they did some cross sectioning
looking at evidence for liver toxicity
and what they found is when they
compared a dis knockout mutation they
found that compared when comparing to
Cephas and black six controls it seemed
to indicate that more liver damage was
present when they knocked out the gene
indicating that that allele was actually
a pedo toxic or excuse me how paddle
protective because when the gene goes
away it begin it becomes worse they did
some more research and they start
looking at the results of least black
6nj versus black 6j and they found that
the results of treating black sex and
mice with acetaminophen very much
different and so that really kind of
flip flopped the results because the
original results is compared to black
six mice really didn't match what was
found in a letter it was literature he
was really understood that this allele
should be hepato toxic and so they did
some more research comparing to the
public controls and ultimately that's
what they found so ultimately comparing
and understanding the genetic background
of the original strain of mice
shown here and comparing the appropriate
controls really is very critical to the
appropriate interpretation of your
scientific results so there's many
different things that you should be
asking about mice and the things that we
are constantly asking about investigator
asking from investigators when they are
building many of those nice to the
jackson laboratory what was the oocyte
donor what ESL line was used to create
those mice what strains have been
introduced through breeding because
people are introducing alleles where
they're using flip recombinases and kri
kri lock system to remove neomycin
cassettes and then developing the mice
further they're using different
reporters to validate their constructs
if it's in a Kree system are there any
other mutations that are known for the
genetic background what's the current
breeding scheme whether it's hep i hat
hat by wild home by home etc that will
influence the need for developing
control colonies etc what is the
generation number how many generations
has this mouse been breeding has it been
bringing over ten generations is it
approaching 20 generations and is that a
mixed genetic background and now that
mixture in the background is a new
inbred strain in and of itself or is it
has been breeding for so many
generations such as a concern for
genetic drift there's a lot of genetic
change within that genetic background
has it ever been crowd preserved so that
you can go back and recover that strain
if anything happens to it or if it has
genetic drifted if it has what
generation was it was it crowded earth
has it ever been back cross to an inbred
strain and how well has it been bad
crossed has the genetic background I've
been validated we can use snip analysis
these days to take a look at that
information and in fact as these do new
embed strains of mice are coming into
the genetic background where we're
running the genetic background to say
well they told us it was c57 black six
well was it black six junior was a black
6n and so when you look at some of our
strain data sheets you'll see data that
looks something like this and if I blow
that up so you can read it a little bit
more clearly we are interrogating it in
bed
crown and if you see something like it's
shown on this slide you can see that
this is it turns out that people that
generate the strain we're using two
different sources of black six mice and
it is it turns out they have a mixed
genetic background between those two and
we're also doing this to say well if you
started out at a 129 substrain and back
cost of black six how successful were
you is there any 129 alleles there so
many of you may be saying well I don't
really know what the source is I got
these mics from a collaborator but I'd
really like to find out so I can do the
most most highest integrity scientific
research possible we do have resources
you can send us a tail tip we can do
what's called a genome scan on those
mines we can find out if your genetic
background is black 6j or black 6 and so
get in touch with us if that would be
helpful to you so again I just want to
raise the question and make you aware
that we have these two inbred strains of
mice so that you can get mice from us
and choose the most appropriate controls
we want the question you may be asking
yourself is well if these mice and these
inbred strains of mice change over time
what about the mice we're distributing
what are we doing to maintain a genetic
integrity of these mice well we have
something that's called the genetic
stability program in recognition of this
so what we're doing is we've created
this enormous frozen library of embryos
from these two inbred strains of mice
and so we're treating these mice
essentially like a tissue culture line
where we only allow these mice to breed
for a few generations and so what we
have is foundation colonies these
foundation stocks are only allowed to
breed for five generations then we go
back to the frozen embryos stock and we
recovered mice from those embryos and
reestablish the the foundation stocks
and these foundation stocks are what we
call the theatre colonies for our
distribution stocks and so we've done a
number of genetic analysis and we've
proven that yes within these five
generations indeed there is some genetic
change that occurs but it goes we go
back to the frozen stock we can
set the genetic clock and so there's
very minimal genetic drift okay so
there's a number of different resources
supporting the c57 black six nice these
are just some examples here when you get
a PDF copy of this presentation these
are all live links you don't have to
copy them down we'll make that freely
available to you so please avail
yourself to some of that important
information and as I mentioned we've got
some of these databases that I mentioned
in the beginning let the mouse genome
database here's that it here's an
example of how you can take advantage of
that you can understand first of all
what this is is in this particular
example of data is looking at baseline
plasma glucose levels of the c57 black
six mice as it compares to a wide range
of number of embed strains of mice and
you can see it's broken down by males
and females and how you can use this
information is let's say you won't have
a genetic mutation you can see how it
modifieds glucose expression on the
genetic background and see how that
influences the allele but you can then
move to different inbred strains of mice
like the ones down in this end and see
how that influence is that metabolic
pathway or you could choose my son mis
end of the spectrum and do that so again
as we're getting closer to the end here
I'd like to encourage you to start
asking some questions and feed them into
the Q&A because we'll be answering some
of those questions in just a moment okay
so one of the things I want to wrap up
at the end here is consider your mouse
whatever your most important reagents
just like if you're choosing a
particular reagent you validate it let's
say you're using your tissue culture you
validate the serum that you use every
time you use it village your mice know
the strain of money that you're working
with understand the genetics behind it
how it breeds know the nomenclature use
the nomenclature when you publish on
that strain so other researchers can
understand which train you're using and
reproduce the data that you're you're
you're producing
publications this will also use less
mice in your research if you are
confused about what inbred strain you're
using you're using multiple remote
strains of mice you have to repeat your
experiments you're using more animals in
your research needlessly so really
understanding of rice and and knowing
what to expect from them can actually
save you money by using rest research
and it's better overall for the
scientific community by using less
animals in research so very quickly in
summary there are multiple genetically
and phenotypic unique strains of inbred
mice out there know what strain you're
working with knowing and understanding
of which blacks except strain you're
working with is key to proper selection
of controls and data interpretation
comparison of phenotypes between black
six substrains will allow you to
identify unique modify or alleles in
fact you can use this as a scientific
advantage we do know that there are
genetic differences between black 6j and
black 6 and so you can compare those two
strains side-by-side genetically for
different phenotypes and actually
identify the genes that are responsible
so it's not a bad thing it can net it
can be a very good thing as long as
you're aware of the differences and
again we have these two inbred strains
of mice they're part of genetic
stability program and they should be
helpful to you to understand that this
is just up here well for those of you
who are new to using nice in your
research please get in touch with us if
you have any questions were happy to
help you out maybe you're a biochemist
to know nothing about working with mice
we can create them rice for you and send
you then send them to you for your needs
we can do individual services etc to
help you and with that i'm going to say
thank you very much for you listening to
me i'm going to hand control back over
to brenda she's going to have a few
conclusion airing remarks and then we're
going to go into a question and answer
period to try to answer some of your
most immediate questions so bear with me
for just a moment like all i pass
control back over to you brenda and dad
that should be it
thank you dr. socca for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I'll
just like to remind our audience how to
submit your questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we will try to
answer as many questions as we can our
first question is dr. Sopher are there
differences between v6n and b 6j as it
concerns gestation and me Thank You
Brenda yeah the question was are there
significant differences between
gestation periods weaning time and
things like that I have not seen any
data to indicate that so far does the
best of my knowledge and everything I've
seen and in our experience in breeding
these mice in our colleagues because
again we do have nice on both standard
backgrounds we're seeing the same wing
time we're seeing similar weight gain
when being fed on the same type of child
diet in the same environment so they're
their typical gestation period for black
six analyses 18 and a half days what
that means is that sometimes a literal
drop on day 18 something a literal some
days sometimes literal drop on day 19 a
lot of that has to do with the
differences have to do with litter size
believe it or not that can influence
gestation period most of our strains
we're going to wean at about three weeks
of age there are a few that are being
wing at four weeks advantage the
influence of weaning mice out longer is
typically influenced by their genetics
in terms of what genetic modification if
they have a neurological defect that
impairs their mobility you might want to
wait and read mice at about four weeks
of age or something like that just to
give them another advantage to get to
their food and things like that okay so
I'm gonna do is pass control back over
now
our next our next question is when is
the right time to renew the colony thank
you yeah the question was when to renew
the colony um our general rule of thumb
is to is that as you follow your
impeding generations you should follow
them by filial generations from one
brother sister mating to the next and as
your start approaching ten filial
generations you want to start thinking
about refreshing the genetic background
there's two different ways that you
could do that we do that regular for the
mice that we distribute so you can just
go back and as your breeding nice you
can occasionally get a few breeding mice
and then infuse them to your calling a
regular basis if it's a unique strain
that only you have and you want them to
be specifically on the CT some black 6j
or NJ what you could do is get some
parental nice from us do a couple back
crosses Lee homozygotes your allele if
it's a homozygous breeding colony and
then expand that line into your colony
the third way that you could do it is if
it's unique string for you once you've
initially created that string one of the
things that we encourage investigators
to do is to cry preserve that strain as
soon as you have a mouse that you fully
characterize it you know the phenotypes
of it you know what to expect from that
Mouse you should cry out preserve it as
your pro Qing things like ten
generations of breeding you can either
do the back last thing I just described
or you can go back to your crap reserve
stock and do your own kind of genetic
stability program take it out
cryopreservation and reset the clock
that way so the short answer is is as
you start approaching ten generations as
I said earlier the beginning to approach
the statistical probability that you've
captured a new genetic mutation in your
colony and you should think about
correct
back down that way okay switch back
maybe dr. Sopher another question is
there any chance to see brown spots on
the floor of a v6 instead of white as a
sign of genetic drift yeah that's a
that's an interesting question we do see
some subtle differences you know these
are supposed to be in red strains of
mice they're supposed to be homozygous
across the genome but we do see some
time at times some slight fluctuations
within a different color asian along the
length of the hair theoretically I guess
the answer might be yes in terms of that
certainly an a dramatic example that is
on one of my earlier slides where we
have seen a spontaneous mutation arise
in new colonies of mice at that Torah
listening so where will you be you'll be
bleeding breeding a mouse on a black 6
background and it spontaneously produces
repeats the production of that point
mutation in a little tyrosinase it
becomes homozygous and you have an
albino mice that occasionally gets
thrown out in the colony so in theory
that that might be an indication but it
not necessarily that's a difficult one
to answer but if you're seeing a very
dramatic shift in coke color it could
mean that there's genetic drift or it
could mean that the strain wasn't
originally appropriately backcrossed so
I thought that they back crossed it for
ten generations but there could be some
background genes and alleles that have
occasionally become homozygous allowing
the expression of some disco color
changes
thank you dr. Sopher we have one more
question are there any differences in
hormonal ii-induced superovulation
responses between v6j and v6n that's a
great question to the best of my
knowledge no but rom what i would
recommend is for you to email that
question into following email address
mice tech at jack's tylorg mi seatme TDC
h @ j XR g i'll come into my group the
technical information services group
that will remind me to try to get that
answer for you because what i could do
is contact our reproductive sciences
group they have a lot of experience with
super ovulation of different invite
strains of mice beyond these two
substrates and I can find out if there
is any statistical variation between
those to the best of my knowledge there
isn't but that would be the best way to
get you a concrete answer that question
so thank you okay we do have time for
one more question and that is can you
suggest two different strains v6 and
some other which would differ in blood
compatibility like in humans I believe
there are no clear blood groups in mice
but there are and are there any
instances where the blood is not
compatible in terms of transfusion ie
the transfusion will cause an immune
conflict directed towards RVC we have a
need to cause a transfusion based in the
movie complication using a mouse model
yeah that's a good question now I'm not
aware of any of those um that's a good
point there aren't any it's not the same
as blood types that you see in the human
population there are some primarily the
difference is associated with the white
blood cells and NH c class 1 class 2
haplotype differences i am not aware of
any red blood cell epitopes that are
differences that were caused some
pronounced technological transfusion
differences yeah I am not aware of any
so unfortunately we are out of time I
want to thank the audience for their
interesting questions and participation
in today's event I'd also like to thank
our sponsor the jackson laboratory for
making today's educational of cast
possible and for dr. brian sober and his
information today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
august 2015 you'll receive an email from
lab roots alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay we invite
you to forward that announcement to any
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event thank you for attending so
next time goodbye